so make a little subheading under this
the key idea I want to get across to you
is how do we convert between bases
there's a lot more to think about under
this heading of number basis it's a huge
topic excuse me but for now let's just
try and get a handle on well how do you
how you work with these things okay so
to indicate that a number is in a base
right what you do is you write that
number like say 47 and you write its
base as a little subscript after so if
I'm writing this is decimal you could
either write it as 47 with a deck which
means decimal or you could write it as
47 with a little 10 which means base 10
okay so I would like to convert this
number into some other base okay so I'm
going to convert it into binary shortly
just to show you how inefficient a
method it is but for reasons that will
become clear shortly that's not a good
first example could do so here's an
example we've all got to try to get up
yuuji convert 47 in base 10 to base 3
now you've seen just here that a lot of
the bases have names so base 10 is
decimal base 2 is binary base 16 is
hexadecimal base 3 also has a name it's
called ternary it's very uncommon but
you can do some cool card tricks with it
and if we have time I'll show you one
but we'll see how we go how do we
convert it let me show you how I'm going
to do all of the working I'm about to do
I'm going to do it in decimal so rather
than write 47 10 and then all these
numbers with tens after them I'm just
going to write this heading decimal and
then everything you're about to see is
decimal well I change it I will indicate
that I'm doing so okay we don't normally
have to say that because we usually do
everything in decimal but we're about to
change that so that's why i'm stading it
explicitly if you're doing working that
you know um convert between different
number systems then you need to say that
ok here's what I want to do here's the
key question you might even like to jot
this down
think of powers of three we're at base
three so you need to think in terms of
powers of three here's why
what does 47 mean we use a place value
system right the 4 and the 7 have
different values not just because
they're different digits but because
there are different places so this 7
means 7 lots of 1 what if the 4 actually
mean it doesn't mean four it means for
lots of 10 right because of course it's
base 10 if I put a number out the front
here like say to that - doesn't mean -
what does that mean yeah we would say oh
you're in the hundreds column now right
the base of 10 is what forms all of
these numbers do you see that okay so
this is really - lots of 10 squared this
is really for lots of 10 - bar one and
this is really seven lots of 10 to the
and if I had decimal points you seem to
like point one all right what is that
one mean that one means one lot of 10 -
bar okay so this is why it makes sense
it's completely internally consistent
right so if we're in base 3 it's not
about these powers of 10 anymore it's
about powers of 3 so tell me 47 what's
the biggest power of 3 you can think of
that fits inside 47:27 seems like the
biggest one right which is 3 cubed I'm
going to write 27 that's the biggest
power of 3 I can fit in there but
there's other numbers as well there's 20
left over ok so I'm doing this working
to try and work out how he power 3 I can
fit in what's the biggest power 4 you
can fit into 20 it's mine well that's
the next power of 3 is it but you can't
just fit one mine company 9 can you fit
in there you can fit two of them
- lots of known - lots of those 18th so
what's left over the end - it's not a
trick question what's the biggest power
of three you can fit into - I guess you
needs three in the power of zero which
is one right four units for you that's
always the last one okay so what I've
got here is 27 plus two of these plus
two of these do you agree and I have the
whole number now right so see this line
here what I'm going to do is I've got to
rewrite it in this form to make clear
what powers of three actually appear in
there right you've got one lot of three
cubed
you've got two lots of three squared
how many lots of three to the one do you
have hmm I don't have any of those keep
that in mind and then I've got two lots
of three to the zero that okay that's
what 47 is so therefore I'm now going to
work within different number systems so
I'm going to stop saying decimal in
front I'm going to say 47 base 10 is
equal to now look at this part carefully
any of these guys do you remember how we
said in base 10 you've got ten digits to
choose from right zero one two three
four etc up to nine and in base two
we're saying you've got two digits to
choose from zero or one how many digits
do we had to change from in base three
three what are the digits zero one and
two and that's why you'll get viewers
and ones and twos the biggest number
you've got is a one then you get a two
I've got three cubes I've got three
squares how many three to the ones did I
have again I don't have any you said
zero and then how many of the unit
so I have to that is 47 in base three
okay